biden orders airstrikes against
facilities used by iran-backed militia
groups
i don't know a ton about this type of
thing but
he probably thought he was ordering
lunch you know
he probably dude i just see him like
every couple of minutes just take a
pocket full of children's hair out of
his like a handful of children's hair
out of his pocket and just
just get that hit baby what
huh hello
who knows man that guy is so old bro
look and i'm telling you
i grew up with an old dad that dude
starting to fall apart
okay are we pretending he's not falling
apart
the dude can't get through a freaking
solid idea
he's mupping it around it's not a safe
place to be i don't feel like
i really don't feel like it's a safe
place to be
because it just feels like if the leader
could be controlled so much
by anyone who even tells them it's nap
time
anyone with a freaking bootleg golden
girls episode
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one